were their death threats there are
people that were wishing that I would
find you know my neck wrapped around a
noose that they will teach me what the
anthem means to them if they see me on
the street people you know wanting to
harm ya and insulting me and my family
my mother has been called a [ __ ] you
know and if you know my mom she's the
sweetest woman yeah and so it's it's sad
it's sad that you know all this hate is
is pushed on to the people this fear
constant you know the media is always
always always negativity and so it riles
people up yeah in its ways public
opinion and people don't do the research
they don't find out what is really going
on and that's the problem so how do you
rebuild after that how do you then
decide you know you're received death
threats - I'm ready to get back on a
stage well how do you how do you rebuild
that you just move forward like anything
you know that you know you fall down you
get back up and there is a reason why
we're here you know in the end you know
when all the currencies run dry when
nothing is a value the only thing you
have is the heart that you've shown to
everybody around you and that's what's
going to allow you to move forward and
rebuild something right if you treat
people in a horrible fashion then that's
going to plague you for the rest of your
life and when the times get tough for
you there won't be people around and I'm
very lucky that I have an amazing family
a great group of friends and one thing
that this has taught me is you know who
your real friends are and who who is
really real around you and who is just
around just for because oh he's a
musician and whatever you know
and you truly find out you know what
people are made of